for most of human history our species
has been trying to solve the problem of
energy how do we stay warm and cook our
food heat our homes and later how do we
power our world and communicate with
each other then 70 years ago we found a
solution that changed everything an
energy Miracle a giant of Limitless
power at man's command
we found out how to throw a tiny Neutron
so hard at a special kind of atom that
it would split apart releasing a huge
amount of energy in a chain reaction
first we mostly use this Chain Reaction
as a weapon the shadow of the atom bomb
has been across all our lives but then
after the war we started using it for
more peaceful things to solve our
age-old energy problem we learned to
control the Chain Reaction creating heat
to boil water and spin a turbine and we
had electricity a lot of electricity all
from this tiny amount of fuel this was
the utopian promise of nuclear power
clean energy for all using the simple
power of an atom within the Adam's heart
is not one but many Giants seeking to
provide vast quantities of energy to run
the world's machines and for a while we
loved it the US started building nuclear
power plants all over the country power
plants started popping up across Japan
and Europe soon France will be getting
nearly three quarters of their power
from nuclear energy all this in a time
of oil crisis when fossil fuels are
expensive and getting scarce the power
of the atom was bringing peace and
prosperity abundance
but then nuclear turned from Darlene to
Outcast there has been a nuclear
accident in the Soviet Union a state of
emergency in two of the country's
nuclear reactors in the worst nuclear
reactor accident today
today nuclear power is in Decline and
I've been trying to understand why why
in an era of climate crisis caused by
fossil fuels are we winding down this
effective carbon-free energy source what
happened to the promise of nuclear
energy inevitably I ended up in a
conversation with my friend Cleo who
makes a show called huge if true she's
someone who's reported on this a bunch
before and was the perfect person to
talk to to help me sort this out why is
nuclear energy not like the saving grace
of our civilization we like sort of gave
up
and I don't understand why and I want to
understand why this is a great story yes
I've looked into this in some ways for
various videos
um but I've never gone straight at it
I've never done the like what the heck
happened with nuclear video I feel like
I will have a clearer version of the
story if we can do it
sort of tag team are we going to do the
cynic Optimist thing I maybe yes here's
the plan I'm going to go down the rabbit
hole on why people are afraid of nuclear
energy like what is the actual deal here
what are the events and the things that
freak us all out and I'm gonna figure
out okay so what do we do about that how
do we use where in the future and we can
compare notes to look at like is there a
future for this technology and should we
actually be as afraid as we are awesome
all right
oh all right
boy I know so much more about nuclear
energy than I did a few weeks ago and
I'm very excited to share it with you
and Cleo is actually on her way right
now like she's about to show up to the
studio and we're gonna do a little show
and tell explainer and it's going to be
very exciting
um but first I need to thank the sponsor
of today's video which is grammarly
grammarly is something I've been using
for ages it's like a tool that helps my
spelling and grammar be better when I'm
writing emails and stuff but they just
came out with something new it's called
grammarly go and it leverages the power
of generative AI the thing we've all
been hearing about to make your writing
better on whatever platform you're
writing on you can tell grammarly go
that you want to make your writing more
exciting more professional shorter and
it integrates with all the platforms
that all of us rely on from Google docs
to Gmail to LinkedIn to whatever
wherever you are on your internet
browser grammarly go is there to make
your writing faster and better a really
common prompt for me lately is video
titles
I will ask like what are 10 video titles
for my video about X Y and Z and I get
really solid responses we all know that
generative AI is Magic and with
grammarly go that magic can be applied
to your writing the other really cool
thing is that it rewrites things like if
you write something you're like I want
this to sound more professional or I
want this to like sound more formal you
literally just highlight it and click a
button and it will spice up your writing
however in whatever Direction you need
it to gremly go is a very cool
application of AI that is from a company
that I've already been using for years
and already know is very legit which is
grammarly so I'm super into it you'll be
amazed at what you can do with this
thing so there's a link in my
description it's grammarly.com Johnny
Harris clicking that link helps support
this channel but it also gets you 20 off
grammarly premium what this is is
grammarly the main product which is the
thing that underlines when you misspell
a word or when your grammar could be
better plus grammarly go which is this
new version of grammarly that uses the
power of generative AI 20 off it's very
affordable and it really can change your
world so thank you grammarly for
sponsoring today's video I think Cleo is
going to be here very soon I can't wait
to show you what we learned about
nuclear energy let's go
[Music]
Welcome to our studio hi hi
I suppose it's normal background
radiation
just some radioactive ways what exactly
is nuclear energy I don't know but I
know someone who does okay let's do this
we went deep in this on very different
sort of aspects of nuclear energy but we
agreed upon three major buckets that are
the reasons we believe that nuclear has
not sort of become the promise of the
future let's call them nuclear's three
big problems and they are
accidents
waste and cost you understand these
three and you really understand
nuclear's big issue or nuclear's big
Solutions
I want to start with accidents because
accidents really are I think the biggest
most powerful thing in our popular
imagination of why nuclear is scary
totally when you think of nuclear power
plants at least for me I thought of like
Chernobyl Chernobyl is this really scary
event that happened in Ukraine in the
late 80s when a nuclear reactor melted
down and then exploded and spewed
radioactive material invisibly into the
sky hundreds of thousands of people had
to evacuate and it turned the entire
area into this like toxic wastelands and
it just has this very sort of scary
apocalyptic energy to it I mean it's the
reason why it's like the subject of this
really popular HBO show Chernobyl led to
the death of hundreds of people I think
a lot of people think it's like come on
tens of thousands of people it was
really hundreds of people from radiation
radiation exactly and then a lot of
people were displaced they had to leave
and that causes a huge disruption and is
a major human cost the numbers aren't
massive here compared to other disasters
that occur but it's the the spectacle of
it like you see this and you see what
radiation does radiation is this really
weird invisible thing that like you
can't see but like suddenly it if you're
exposed to it in high doses it can start
to like break down the very building
blocks of of your cells and just sort of
deteriorate your body like from the
inside like it's really sort of gruesome
and hard to think about and look at and
I think that leaves an impression on
people this isn't the only event that
has happened here in the United States
we had a nuclear accident at Three Mile
Island 147
000 people had to temporarily evacuate
it led to no deaths but I think that's
surprising for a lot of people I think
it is too again because the spectacle
more recently there was a nuclear
disaster the third sort of big one in
Japan after an earthquake off the coast
of Japan it created this like massive
tsunami that washed up onto Fukushima
and there was a nuclear plant there that
got completely overrun and broken down
and had another meltdown okay but it's
not just accidents think about having
this invisible scary thing called
radiation and if you are someone who
wants to do harm and you get your hands
on this stuff you can turn it into a
weapon and you're not even talking about
controlling nuclear proliferation by
focusing on where people get uranium and
enrichment and all of that you're you're
focusing on once nuclear power plants
are built there's a security risk
absolutely and you see this in like
polls and stuff you have this public
opinion poll here in the United States
that asks Americans if they think we
should use nuclear at all not like
should it be the number one source or
should we invest in it it's should we
even use it as one of our sources and
look almost 50 percent of people don't
think we should even have it at all like
we should do away with nuclear power
it's perfectly split yeah it's a 50 50.
the percentage of people who say that
nuclear power is safe is going down
every year and is it 47 percent what
happened in 2011 that Fukushima and it
didn't me too like I feel this I feel
this association with nuclear power
because of these events this is Japan
and nuclear is in yellow right after
Fukushima you see that nuclear power in
Japan just gets kind of squashed so I
think for me the reason why accidents is
like the top of this list is because
accidents have this big psychological
effect on people I think we need to
separate out though risk of accidents
which are terrifying from safety of an
energy source because those are actually
two different things what we really want
to know isn't how many accidents happen
it's deaths per unit of electricity
production so like every electricity
source is risky in its own way and you
can measure how many people die based on
how much energy you make yes this is the
data for solar nuclear wind and
hydropower okay so what you can see is
that they don't have that many deaths
per unit of electricity production what
this is saying is that these are all
really really safe energy sources and
nuclear is between solar and wind like
this is really important oh wait I
didn't even see that nuclear was down
there yeah okay this includes all deaths
from accidents and nuclears between our
two most exciting renewable energy
sources
And yet when we think of nuclear we
think of danger yes if you think about
our energy Max how much power we get
from different sources of energy
holy sh that is fossil fuels here's the
data that really drove this home for me
so our welding data that's the source of
the chart that I just showed did a
calculation to really show people how
this affects actual humans so what they
did is they set up a town called
euroville This is a hypothetical town of
150 000 people nice
and uravil uses one terawatt hour of
electricity per year if you powered
euroville for one year with just coal
this is the number of citizens of
euroville that would die if you chose
oil if you powered euroville for one
year with just oil this many people
would die coal is actually 25 oil is 18.
okay
one year
in a town of 150 000 people those are
real humans with families and lives and
and jobs if you chose gas
three people
if you chose hydropower
one person if you chose wind nuclear or
solar it would take 25 years for one
person to die
25 years I think it is totally
understandable to focus on how scary
accidents are I don't mean to say like
look at this data like we're so
irrational yeah but I do think that if
we really cared about human lives we
would be paying a lot more attention to
how many people fossil fuels kill and we
would be trying really really hard to
replace fossil fuels with wind nuclear
solar or hydropower as fast as human as
possible and this is before we get to
climate change yeah
this is just production of these energy
sources yeah it's not the carbon
ramifications that's another reason but
it's separate from this I think it's
that the accidents
are just inherently scary and the same
way that like a plane crash is scary
it's a spectacle
coal and oil is like car crashes it
happens way more but we don't really pay
attention just genuinely surprised I
would have guessed nuclear was higher up
I really would have after the question
of actual deaths from nuclear power and
other energy sources there's also this
question of a fear of radiation you see
it in the headlines all the time about
living next to a nuclear plant or
working in a nuclear plant or whatever
yep and again the thing here is about
our human brains assessing risk so these
are a bunch of sources of radiation and
this is the Spectrum that's going to
help us compare them so what do you get
from a typical chest CT scan compared to
taking a flight from New York to Tokyo
yeah give me one clue so this one is can
cause radiation sickness radiation
sickness is if you're up at a thousand
yeah
that's scary guess where are the other
things okay I'm going to start with
flight versus x-ray like chest x-ray
like I get a checks x-ray I go on a
flight from New York to Tokyo I'm
assuming that a flight isn't crazy so
like maybe one
and then the chest x-ray is probably
like
10. man I'm probably so off
all right so I'm gonna go here I'm gonna
go here did I do them all so what I'm
seeing from your guesses are you are
aware that we get radiation from all
kinds of stuff from flying from chesty
tees from chest x-rays all of that but
you have an impression that if you live
next to a nuclear power plant or if you
work in a nuclear power plant you're
like signing up for more yeah and it's
probably not like crazy you're gonna get
cancer but like you're getting a little
bit more radiation than if you're just
like living way far away right okay here
are the real answers so a couple things
make total sense the annual amount
received by a worker in a nuclear power
plant is lower than the maximum annual
dose but a typical dose from living
within a few kilometers of an operating
nuclear power plant for one year is less
than a typical chest x-ray and way less
than a typical chest CT scan and less
than a flight from New York to Tokyo wow
living next to it for a year you're
living next to it for an entire year and
in one like 10 hour flight you are
getting more radiation exposure a a lot
more and also this one is super
important this is the average total dose
from natural background radiation this
is what all of us are getting no matter
what
from living on Earth in our particular
solar system that is significantly more
than
living next to a nuclear power plant
um working within a nuclear power plant
the major lesson from all of this is
most of the radiation exposure that
you'll get in your life will be from
plane trips and x-rays and natural
background radiation even if you lived
right next to a nuclear power plant even
if you worked in a nuclear power plant
wow okay radiation is probably another
one of these sort of invisible scary
things that we maybe over index on our
hesitation about because we don't
understand it and I that's how I feel
radiation to me is invisible it is scary
what it does to us is scary and
so I sort of associate like proximity to
things that create radiation I.E nuclear
power plant as like oh well that's the
source of it if I'm close to it I'm
probably getting it because I can't
really see it again like none of what
I'm saying is meant to imply that
that aren't disastrous and terrifying or
that radiation in doses that are on the
upper end of the spectrum is also
disastrous and terrifying I just made a
video about cancer it scared the heck
out of me but that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't also put it into context we
should put all of that data into context
and comparing deaths to deaths from
fossil fuels and comparing radiation to
ways that we receive radioactive other
ways this is just about putting that
risk in context into perspective okay
okay wow that definitely like
complicates the nuclear is scary because
of accidents kind of narrative that I
think is very much alive in the in the
popular like perception of this energy
source the the thing that keeps flowing
in mind is that the fossil fuel number
like that that is just still very much
in my mind right now okay can we move on
yes okay wow accidents these other two
are I think less huge but still
important
um one thing that we hear a lot about
waste I saw a tweet recently from
Greenpeace that was like nuclear energy
isn't like viable for the future the
waste problem is still a thing and that
sort of sent me down this Rabbit Hole
the first thing I think of is like Homer
Simpson and like green goop like nuclear
waste that's like never it's like in a
barrel somewhere and it can like sneak
out and Destroy everyone
I know that is a caricatured version of
it but there is a reality that when we
do fission when we break apart atoms to
make energy there is a byproduct of that
in fact I have a chart here actually
most of nuclear waste is not like some
like scary material but the thing that
scares people is actually this little
three percent it's the vast minority of
what nuclear waste comes out of this
process and it is the spent fuel this is
scary because this is stuff that comes
out and gets put into like big barrels
okay and it gets stored on site like at
the nuclear power plant every year we
make relatively not a ton of this stuff
it's about the size of half of an
Olympic swimming pool okay so it's not
like a ton relative to how much energy
we get out of it but like the thing
that's scary is that this stuff doesn't
go away there's this really clunky chart
that you don't really need to look at
all the lines on what you need to look
at is that x-axis down here yeah you
look down here and you just see really
really big numbers this is how long this
waist stays radioactive and yes you're
looking at a number that says one
million over here human beings have
existed in this form for like 200 000
Years and we're talking about creating a
dangerous material that lives on
potentially for hundreds of thousands of
years if not a million years before it
becomes benign again that is a problem
and this isn't just like in one facility
like this isn't like all centralized in
one place like if you look at this map
of the US this is where all of these
sites are like there are a lot of them
so there's a lot of points of failure as
time goes on you can see how this could
just build up and become like a massive
management task I have this very
instinctive fear of this stuff yeah I
think one of the things that helps is to
look at what it is in my imagination
nuclear waste this green goop nuclear
waste is actually
a solid pellet so we are trying to
dispose of a solid material that is
extremely radioactive at most nuclear
power plants we have these they're
called dry casks so basically
those fuel pellets that look like this
go into a column inside a metal rod it's
just about half an inch across and then
all of those rods together are bundled
into a fuel assembly okay then those are
put inside of a one of those big cats
that you should
um and then they're covered in concrete
there's an outer shell there's a sealed
inner cylinder these things are built to
withstand tornadoes and direct attacks
and floods and every possible natural
disaster that you can imagine and
they're certified for about 40 years
obviously that is nothing in the time
scale of radioactivity people look at
the difference between that time scale
they're like oh my God hundreds of
thousands of years that doesn't mean
that there are lots of uncertified
unsafe dry casks all around the country
like in the research that I was doing I
didn't find a single instance of a
radiation leak from a dry Cask or a
single instance of an attack on a dry
cast that liberally meant to do harm
yeah that doesn't mean that there
couldn't possibly be leaks and it
doesn't mean there couldn't possibly be
a tax but just in this in terms of what
we're really talking about here and risk
assessment I think for me it's I'm like
cool it's only this big now but what's
gonna happen next in the long run other
countries are doing what's called Deep
geological storage oh wow so what you in
theory want to do is assemble those fuel
pellets into those fuel rods into those
canisters
um and these are the canisters are
slightly different but then you bury
them deep deep underground there are
some countries that have already built
systems like this Finland is one there
are lots of countries that are
investigating them this is a technology
that is totally difficult and impressive
that we can do but it's being tried it's
being done this is feasible and in fact
if you go back to the chart that we were
using you might have heard of Yucca
Mountain which was the United States
effort to do deep theological Repository
Yucca Mountain failed for lots and lots
of reasons some local politics but again
this is a primarily political problem
not a technological one
yeah I think that like I definitely feel
this sense and I think this is probably
a pretty popular
reaction to this which is like
we have this like hot potato and we like
need to get rid of it so we put it in
these casks that are only good for 40
years and then it's like that's gonna
run out so let's just like bury it in a
giant hole and like make it go away but
it's still going to be there I think I
kind of share the reticence of having
a an energy source that just continually
produces this as a byproduct even if we
do have these these Technologies can you
find a way to have it not have a
byproduct please
actually not quite but
so think about this this waste the
reason why the waste that we just talked
about is scary is that it's radioactive
which means that there's energy in this
solid yep yep yep that's also a really
exciting prospect because there are ways
that we can use that energy and not only
does that give us an energy source it
also allows us to shorten the
radioactive lifespan of nuclear weapons
of the waste down from potentially
thousands of years to if you do this
enough hundreds of years so you can use
nuclear waste as fuel for more energy
you can recycle nuclear waste yes I
dived all the way into this in a video
that I'm now going to promise is going
to be on my channel by the time we air
this one so it's live right now on your
channel yes you better be because I just
I'm promising that it is
deep dive on nuclear recycling that I
need to watch so here's the visual to
just keep in mind this is the way that
the United States does this right now
okay they mine it it goes into uranium
they put it into a reactor and then it
creates scary waste and then they have
to put it somewhere exactly and
ways
but that are closed fuel Cycles so we
have an open fuel cycle it's one line
but there are closed fuel Cycles where
various different kinds of reactors can
actually recycle nuclear waste so that
you're getting more energy out of the
nuclear fuel itself and also cutting
down on the radioactive God that seems
like a game changer and just for all the
people out there right now who are
saying that seems totally infeasible
Japan already does it whoa this is a
much too complicated visualization of
Japan's nuclear fuel cycle but they've
been recycling nuclear fuel for years
yeah this is a huge game if this could
actually happen at scale like if this
could actually be applied
then you really cut down on one of what
I see and actually feel is like a major
stumbling block for this energy source
that is a game changer huge of sure huge
if true
nice that was perfect Okay so we've done
accidents we've done waste both of those
are really associated with fear of bad
things happening in the long run
especially and
um the third one is like not bad like
the third one is just the plain old
numbers it's just Cost and this is
actually like perhaps like the most cut
and dry which is that nuclear costs more
than everything else and it's gone up
over time like meanwhile you've got this
yellow line which is solar and it's just
like
like there's been so much investment
there's been so much innovation in this
dipped down look at that that's like
we've gotten so good at making solar
cheap and it's obviously been invested
in by the government but like nuclear is
expensive and that's a problem is this
worth it is the conversation that we
should all be having and not from a
place of fear but from a place of
evaluating what the best bang for our
buck is to stop using fossil fuels and
use clean energy sources yeah and if
that's not nuclear and if we have better
Solutions in Renewables awesome yeah
like that's great totally but it has to
be based on what's best
for us not based on calling out one
specific energy source and creating an
environment of fear around it without
context absolutely the question like you
mentioned is always how much do we
actually invest in creating these energy
sources in causing this Innovation and
causing this price decline this this
chart shows government subsidies for
various kinds of energy you've got
fossil fuels in blue you got renewable
energy and yellow you're at nuclear
energy very small and green and you can
see obviously that we're investing more
and more Renewables which is awesome the
question that we have to ask about this
chart is how does it compare to the
amount of energy that we get from each
of these sources because it just
perfectly lines up then it's just dollar
for dollar investing yeah the answer is
when you compare how much we're
investing in each kind of energy versus
the amount of energy that that Source
actually gives us right now what you see
is that nuclear is a little bit less
than Renewables these days
um in terms of our full Energy Mix but
it's getting invested in way less yeah
which why is that is it because of the
fear like it's probably because of these
like big concerns that we've talked
about I think we're now in a situation
where we're operating a lot of old
nuclear power plants that are no longer
competitive with the new sources of
energy that we've been investing in and
those new sources of energy are
amazing like that's great but we did
strangle a potential clean energy source
in a lot of ways yeah and so I'm not
totally sure to be honest whether that
fact that nuclear isn't competitive is
because of a loss of innovation and
investment that could have happened
years ago or because it was never going
to be Renewables and kind of at this
point it doesn't matter like yeah we are
where we are yeah I think that at the
very least I would hope that we're
evaluating this based on the
Technology's ability to help us as
opposed to based on a lot of
fear-mongering over decades yeah and I
think what I found is that the fear and
the concerns
are really kind of sticky you can't make
an HBO mini-series about like an
accident at a solar farm I think after
talking to you about this I feel like
there's a lot more to the story that if
invested in if looked into has a lot of
potential and that potential maybe
hasn't been able to be fully realized I
don't know if this wins out in the long
run but I think it needs a fairer shot
than it's been given I think that's my
takeaway too cool for me I'm going to
watch this really closely in coming
years to see if like this turns around
and like we actually do check our fears
and realize that there is promise in
this energy and we really kind of don't
have another choice we have to figure it
out and because we're so wrapped up in
our fears about nuclear power we didn't
even talk about innovation in nuclear
energy new kinds of nuclear reactors new
kinds of fuels that we might use there's
an enormous part of this conversation
that's like we can talk about nuclear
ads that exist today we can also talk
about the future and that's something
that I'm really excited to do I think
you can only do that frankly after you
begin to unpack this part
and so what I loved about this is like
it felt like you were bringing the
concerns that very reasonable people
have about nuclear energy but then we
were able to talk about the context
around each of those because the
ultimate question when we talk about
energy sources is always compared to
what yeah deaths from nuclear accidents
in my opinion should always be compared
to deaths from other energy sources yeah
radiation should always be compared to
radiation from other sources investment
in Acts should always be compared to
investment and why and so I think when
we are talking about how we get energy
in the future
I think this conversation has to be
compared to what what kind of future do
we want to have and how do we get there
yeah all right on my webcams Mr Burns is
making me eat all these Drums of toxic
waste jeez that's rough there must be
two 300 gallons in here yeah and even a
teaspoon could cause a fatal tumor
hey you want to cut Bola with us tonight
okay okay that's it that's the video
that is a video that Claire and I have
been working on for a very long time
talking about for potentially years and
now we've finally done it and yes we
used overhead projectors and
transparencies which is surprisingly
useful like I understand why this was
like the story of my elementary school
life
very useful visual display mechanism so
another video is over and I need to
quickly show you something one sec
check out my map poster I mean you can't
really see it super well here so let's
just hit cut to it there we go okay this
is a poster that I've been thinking
about for years and is finally real it
is a printed thing it's called all maps
are wrong and it shows all of the map
projections not all of them a bunch of
them that we use to take a spherical
Earth and put it on a flat plane and I
love it and it's beautiful and I got a
lot of help designing it from some good
friends and some people on our team and
it's just a very very special product
for me so that is on sale if you want
this poster to live on your wall
um you can it lives on my wall and will
be next to my desk forevermore so that I
can look at map projections all day long
[Applause]
that's a major way that you can support
this channel by the way more and more we
rely on our community to support our
independent journalism we have a growing
team and it takes resources and time to
build these videos and so your support
is very very appreciated we also have a
community over at The Newsroom which is
our patreon this is a place where you
can come and support every month and you
get something in return a behind the
scenes Vlog that we do some people show
up to patreon just to support us and
they don't want anything in return but
if you do this is a fun thing to see how
our operation Works how we make what we
make the people and the processes Behind
these videos you also get access to my
scripts and music and a bunch of things
that could be useful too we have Luts
and presets that help color our video
and photo also many of you don't know
that I started a company a few years ago
it's called bright trip it's a place
where we make courses about how to
travel smarter
um brighttrip.com
and I think that's basically
um thank you all for being here for
watching today's video uh we've got a
lot coming up and I will see you in the
next one
bye everyone
all right impact marathon is over
foreign
[Music]